en este vídeo vamos a hablar de
relaciones proporcionales son relaciones
entre dos variables en donde la razón
entre las variables es equivalente ahora
eso suena complicado o un poco
caprichoso pero espero que se vea más
claro una vez que hayamos visto algunos
ejemplos digamos que estamos haciendo
una receta de algo que tenemos que
hornear tal vez algo así como
panquecitos y más tarde estaré haciendo
muchos sabemos cuántas tazas de leche
necesitamos para un cierto número de
huevos entonces tenemos número de huevos
y también tenemos tazas de leche en esta
receta sabemos que si usamos un huevo
tenemos que usar dos tazas de leche si
usamos tres huevos vamos a usar seis
tazas de leche y si usamos digamos doce
huevos entonces vamos a usar 24 tazas de
leche esto es una relación proporcional
donde las variables son las tasas de
leche y el número de huevos bueno para
comprobarlo tenemos que pensar en la
razón
estas dos variables y podemos decir la
razón del número de huevos a tazas de
leche o la razón de tazas de leche a
número de huevos pero debemos
asegurarnos de que sean equivalentes en
cualquiera de los escenarios así que
déjenme hacer otra columna aquí y voy a
pensar en la razón de huevos a tazas de
leche
bueno en este primer escenario un huevo
a dos tazas de leche en el segundo
escenario es 36 en el tercer escenario
es 12 a 24 estas razones son
equivalentes bueno para ir de 1 a 3
multiplicamos por 3 y para ir de 2 a 6
también multiplicamos por 3 de modo que
multiplicamos las dos variables por 3 de
la misma forma si multiplicamos el
número de huevos por 4 también
multiplicamos el número de tazas de
leche por 4 así que estas son sin duda
razones equivalentes 1 2 3 a 6 y 12 a 24
en cada uno de los escenarios tenemos el
doble de tazas de leche que de número de
huevos
esto es proporcional verificado ahora
cuál sería el ejemplo de una relación no
proporcional nos quedaremos pensando en
los productos horneados digamos que
vamos a una tienda de pasteles y tenemos
curiosidad de saber cuánto cuesta
comprar un pastel para diferentes
números de personas
entonces digamos número de porciones en
una columna y luego el costo del pastel
y dejen nacer dos columnas digamos que
si tenemos diez porciones el pastel
cuesta 20 pesos
si tenemos 20 porciones el pastel cuesta
30 pesos y si tenemos 40 porciones el
pastel cuesta 40 pesos pausa en el vídeo
y traten de saber si esta es una
relación proporcional si lo es por qué y
si no lo es porque no muy bien pensemos
en las razones nuevamente aquí nuestras
dos variables son el número de porciones
y el costo del pastel
entonces si vemos la razón de porciones
a costo
en esta primera situación es de 10 a 20
luego es de 20 a 30 y luego es de 40 a
40 de modo que para saber si son razones
equivalentes cuando vamos de 10 a 20 en
el número de porciones estamos
multiplicando por 2 pero cuando vamos de
20 a 30 en el costo del pastel no
estamos multiplicando por 2 estamos
multiplicando por 1.5 o por 1 y medio y
de forma similar cuando vamos de 20 a 40
estamos multiplicando por 2 nuevamente
pero para ir de 30 a 40 no estamos
multiplicando por 2 estamos
multiplicando por 1 y un tercio por 1 y
un tercio cuando multiplicamos el número
de porciones por una cantidad dada no
estamos multiplicando el costo del
pastel por la misma cantidad esto nos
indica que no es proporcional
una manera de pensar en relaciones
proporcionales como ya hemos dicho es
que la razón entre las variables sea
equivalente otra forma de pensar en esto
es que una de las variables siempre es
una constante por la primera variable de
modo que nuestro primer ejemplo dijimos
que el número de tazas de leche siempre
será 2 multiplicado por el número de
huevos podemos escribirlo las tazas de
leche siempre serán iguales a 2
multiplicado por el número de huevos a
este número que tenemos aquí le llamamos
constante de proporcionalidad no podemos
hacer una ecuación como ésta para este
escenario eso sería mucho más complicado
de modo que en las relaciones
proporcionales las razones entre las dos
variables son equivalentes y podemos
establecer una ecuación como ésta en la
que tenemos una constante de
proporcionalidad
hasta el próximo vídeo